nachdem ich ein jahr des wunderschönen
zusammenlebens mit ihm hatte gingen die
ersten wirklichen attacken los dass er
mich klein gemacht hat dass er meinen
selbstwert herunter gesetzt hat ich es
ab und dem moment nicht so empfunden
oder gespürt habe vier jahre lang wurde
romy stange von ihrem partner geschlagen
und misshandelt vier jahre von
körperlicher und seelischer gewalt diese
zeit ist jetzt vorbei heute setzt sie
sich in münchen für betroffene von
häuslicher gewalt ein aus dem wirklichen
attacken wurden auch handgreifliche
attacken die im schlussendlichen dann
auch daran geändert haben dass ich
eingesperrt wurde heute am gg spreche
ich über eine pandemie ein globales
virus viel älter als profi 19 aber nicht
weniger verheerend sexualisierte und
geschlechterspezifische gewalt zu
stürzen jahren des lebens und frauen und
kindern weltweit die statistik ist
eindeutig jeden dritten tag starb eine
frau durch ihren partner oder ex-partner
in deutschland allein im letzten jahr
gab es 139 opfer die noch
frauenministerin christine lambrecht hat
eine klare botschaft für den tag gegen
gewalt an frauen wir müssen mehr wissen
wir müssen sensibler werden es kann
heute schon mit dem strafrecht
entsprechend erfasst werden aber es muss
auch konsequent verfolgt werden auch die
grünen-politikerin ricarda lang fordert
strengere maß ich habe gerade bei rca
blicken cbs die korona pandemie zu einer
zunahme von häuslicher gewalt und gewalt
gegen frauen geführt hat eine krisenzeit
wo viele menschen auf ihre eigenen vier
wände zurück geworfen waren und wie sie
das genau diese eigenen vier wände also
der ort an dem man sich sicher fühlen
uns heute für viele frauen der und
sicherste ort sind am ende an gefährlich
und sogar ein tödlicher ort nach dem
gewaltschutzgesetz habe ich heute schon
die möglichkeit dass der täter der der
schlägt rausfliegt aus der wohnung und
nicht die familie die wohnung verlassen
muss und das muss viel konsequenter
umgesetzt werden weltweit kommt es zu
protesten gegen gewalt an frauen die
istanbul konvention des europarats ist
das internationale abkommen zur
bekämpfung
geschlechtsspezifischer gewalt gegen
frauen und mädchen da 2018 ist die
konvention in deutschland geltendes
recht die effektive umsetzung dieser
kann eine lösung sein wir sehen dass wir
gerade bei den zahlen frauenhaus plätzen
weit von der eu-kommission abfallen auch
was eine flächendeckende prävention
angeht und deutschland immer noch einen
vorbehalt was die situation von frauen
die keinen eigenen aufenthaltstitel in
deutschland haben verein gebaut wir
brauchen eine vorbehaltlose umsetzung
der istanbul konvention gewaltschutz für
alle frauen keine frau in diesem land
soll mehr angst um ihr leben haben und
vor allem soll sie dann wenn sie gewalt
erfährt den zugang zu schutz haben denn
dass es eigentlich ein menschenrecht
hinter diesen zahlen stehen geschichten
die oftmals im vorfeld schon nicht als
das erkannt werden was sie sind das
heißt jede einzelne frau die stirbt die
häusliche gewalt erlebt hat nicht den
schutz erfahren oder die hilfe die es
braucht ich finde gerade in anbetracht
der tatsache dass jeden tag in
deutschland versucht seine partnerin
umzubringen ist jede frau die in einem
frauenhaus abgewiesen wird es jedes
frauenhaus das wegen mangelnder
finanzierung schließen muss eigentlich
ein skandal
wir brauchen gewaltschutz für alle
frauen egal welcher herkunft egal
welchem sozialen status und dafür
brauchen wir eine gut finanzierte
gewaltschutz infrastruktur lasst uns
genau hinsehen und habe um hilfe gefragt
ist heute bin ich nach zehn jahren die
er selbst arbeitet dann auch und das
mich entscheidend dass ich nicht mehr in
die ecke gehen möchte wo ich traurig bin
wohl etwas mitgemacht möchte ich nach
vorne schauen und möchte frauen eine
hand reichen die ihnen hilft aber auch
auf der anderen seite jemand sein der
aus klärt der das thema aus der tabuzone
geholt und der etwas versucht im kleinen
zu bewegen die opfer von
gewaltverbrechen
statt gewalt gegen mädchen und frauen
das ist aufmerksam macht dass es
rauskommt aus der tabu-zone dass niemand
das gefühl hat damit kann ich jetzt
nicht an die öffentlichkeit gehen da bin
ich alleine womöglich bin ich sogar
selbst dran schuld sondern dass es mut
macht sich zu wehren und ich verspreche
dass wir in den nächsten vier jahren
alles tun werden um eine regierung auf
den weg zu bringen die dieses recht
endlich umsetzt in gesetzen in der
praxis und in der gesellschaft ich
fordere an dem tag gegen gewalt an
frauen dass wir als gesellschaft
hinschauen das wird das thema häusliche
gewalt aus der tabu ecke uhr in wo es
ist dass wir aktiv zivilcourage leben
das wir betroffenen frauen eine hand
reichen dass wir auf politischer ebene
einfach aktiv und mit aller kraft daran
arbeiten das schutzsystem
lückenlos aufzustellen dass frauen die
hilfe bekommen die sie benötigen und
dass wir einfach einen ort in
deutschland schaffen wo gewalt kein
thema mehr ist